in today's video we have a beautiful
town and 100 players trapped in a box
beautiful and oh my gosh is this video
gonna be cool there's gonna be TNT rainy
there's gonna be lots of lava you don't
understand don't this is probably gonna
be our craziest video okay Chris yeah
flip that switch yeah no Chandler Carl
you guys are competing go to your own
calls yes sir and now all 100 people are
squirming around like the little ant
Caesar
where are you I am are you the only one
in blue be Oh worries oh my gosh
Carl okay go go I'm following you and
following you into the we'll be right
it'll be about to die I'm gonna die no
stop stop okay okay Oh tea is raining
dojo building everyone you need to go
inside they're just standing here go
inside JFK JFK hold on wait I can get a
lead you gotta make it inside if you
don't go inside you will be punished
hold on I got it I got you bud oh wait I
can't lead him what do you do when it
rains you go inside all the I feel bad
for everyone not going inside he's
hiding behind a tree okay I will save
you anime girl the map is blowing up I
will say if you animate no anime girl
whoever's last to survive this raining
TT wins $10,000 who are you
you should be honored should he be on
our team yeah he looks like he's empty
and happy alright buddy okay he's on our
scone we condone oh my gosh
how is it going through the ceiling yo
I'm getting blocks I'm just collect
blocks boys we can do this Oh again
dude we should make our own little thing
where the TNT doesn't spawn you know
what I'm saying yeah here little island
all right I need blocks I need I'm gonna
take this wood slab and this door
because I like doors what is this okay
and rod you want some n rod Carl yes I'd
love and rod thank you 64 players are
currently still alive and look the TNT
is raining even harder go ahead
come on buddy I'm saving you guys go up
the stairs do you want ten grand survive
the higher you go up to the buildings to
crater your chance of survival but they
don't know that go up
go up base one of the reigning TNT is
pulling up all the blocks out here I
need a gone
TNT gods destroy the block none of my
children oh no my child the blocks keep
falling on this staircase that players
all over this building all over this
John players everywhere boom alright
I wonder how Carl and Chandler are doing
oh my gosh look at the ground
oh I guess we aren't going down we're
turning this into our own house you see
that goal block in the corner what if it
is a safe block there's only one goal
block in the home and I don't see yeah
yeah we should get to that block let's
do that for sure okay look at this block
all the way over there operation gold
block safe zone and now that the map has
been blown to smithereens EVP is now
being turned on boom they can now hurt
each other what will they do with this
power I'm it's here two-time champ TT is
back alright
it is now raining again but they can
fight each other what will happen
all right TT is falling oh no targeting
no target chris is gearing him block him
off chris is gearing him up umm I'm
blocking it off alright I'm taking a
water tip wash my back Oh
38 John's for me no a lot of people have
died so far a lot of people are stuck
ignore this black bar right here I'm not
a professional you have five minutes to
kill someone or you will be yeah Jimmy
look at this I put very good loot out
here but they got a parkour to it I
actually have no way of tracking if they
kill each other that's just the bluff to
you know get the numbers down he's
trying to kill someone because he thinks
if he doesn't he'll get kicked but he
won't this guy just got oh the tnt is
back as well to make it harder here I'm
gonna go from behind and knock them off
should I try that yeah I'm bait okay
Batum Batum tell me if he moves tell me
if he moves he's just looking at me
[Music]
what
no have ad survived oh yeah oh cool I
found what's up guys
Oh Oh Carl you're gonna run away from me
alright find that give me give me Oh
Jimmy's got a bucket of lava Oh Oh
Kelly's lava
stop they keep trying to knock me off
hey stuck I'm stuck no dude we killed
someone till we killed somebody
interesting interesting but you're gonna
have to kill someone else hey there you
go Chandler
alright only one of you could survive
good luck boys hey Chandler yo Taylor
you have earned the right to live go
through jelly get out of this call yeah
screw you traitor all right let's see if
he's dumb enough to do this right there
does he want it does he want it he fall
for the trap will he fall for the trail
he saw me move it okay well back up Oh
what okay whoa hey we will bow down to
you you are God you're great Chris I
think we spice things up a little bit I
like spice spice is nice not the food I
want to TP everyone's still alive right
here gotcha
hold up make sure you don't TV all the
proud people Oh Betty clever sitting
pretty ruin the whole challenge I did
almost ruin the entire chat
- Oh bro bro bro Oh brah brah brah
no oh my god boy should I just kill
Chandler oh oh I will never help you
again you will never win another
challenge I swear alright so I'm at the
guy who killed Chandler this is poor
Jedi as a reward here's a bucket a
reward that takes guts to kill you man
takes guts with a wooden sword below
much guts to betray me let's talk about
betrayal Chandler dude I'm sober here
right now I'm moving my body which means
it's typey time we now have a diamond
platform here they have five minutes to
get on this diamond platform shop mr.
beast is on his way this is what you get
for being a trader it's gonna take you
ten minutes to get down this building
there's just one person that's got
pretty much diamond I'm moving I'm
moving back no longer being typing
jimmy-boy Jedi still trying to make his
way down or Jedi don't mess this jump up
don't mess it up
how does that happen Chandler how does
that make you feel great makes me feel
great
everyone still live is now in the
diamond platform and they are still
competing for ten macadamia nuts now
what we're gonna do guys we're gonna
split this platform into fours I don't
care who's in what quadrant just split
in the forest let them pick their sides
they all on their own free will
picked a quadrant now wall off the
quadrant so they can't see each other
[Music]
PvP is still off you guys are now in
four quadrants only one person from each
quadrant will live wait this guy
switched oh wait he's doing the same
thing no he doesn't want to face the guy
with diamond armor hey like he's so sad
he's like why do I have to face this man
wait this person has two swords Chandler
start giving away stuff we get these
villas everyone be giving boys ok
everybody get one come on come one come
on come get you here come get you I'm
gonna throw a bow and a few arrows
alright Chris tell them and 10 seconds
PvP will be on lava turn on PvP
good luck contestants alright here we go
I got the lung v1 they're going for it
already
oh no all the kid and all the diamond he
stole everything diamond oh he's already
won that Oh to the other corners alright
oh no three shot mr. BC me show the
Beast
gastly gasping oh okay our winners are
gastly gasps shot mr. B's Attica and a
no cookie gamer at cos my boy or girl
yeah oka gotta hook them all up with a
full diamond armor and diamond swords at
cos a companion he's got a can a
companion cat a cat painting these are
the four people that remain boys how we
spiced enough this final duel well I
already added a cat we're gonna let the
contestants decide how this goes I'm
just gonna continue all four sides and
we'll just see what happens all right
I'm not here we'll all connect the other
sides of the Catherine out I'm
connecting them right now all right
connect the birdie go all right there
yep connective connective all sides now
meet in the middle let's see what they
do
got you anka hold on
all right they're all in the same right
now all right oh he got the careful I
gave it this is for ten grand
tennis I mean that's oh my god oh he
tried to run away oh oh all right we got
this
go back fight get back your night I'm
coming the other sizes low shop Oh Oh
Thomas More's that cut who's gonna win
oh it's gonna happen so I'm into actors
not even taking damage you just won
$10,000 my hardest
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Carl Carl okay give us a good old
yeehaw
hey Chris Chris can give us a good old
yeah boy yeah Chandler can you put the
cheese balls cheese balls I just wanna
say thank you for all of you and Carl
because the cat was my mascot or Cabala
cats oh yeah you don't want to say thank
you to the person who gave you the
diamond Armour that's fine or actually
how about how about the guy who's
literally giving you the $10,000 but
good job Carl could spawn cats they
congratulations on your 10 credit thank
you all for coming out subscribe